pensate che sia un click bait sta roba
invece invece no non è un click day the
shell libro riello neighbours serio
sapete tutti che cos'è lo nei board
spero perché ci ho fatto un sacco di
episodi sul canale
se non lo sapete perché non mi è
arrivata la notifica andate a vederli
gioco che è rimasto in alpha per un
sacco di tempo in fase di sviluppo è
finalmente uscito hanno fatto anche il
libro gliel'ho network schiavello
neighbor i pezzi mancanti
la casa produttrice trovato e quella del
di farina del freddy's quella del
castoro
ecco questo in teoria dovrebbe essere il
castoro ma il focus della mia
videocamera non è così tanto buono se
non a mettermi riquadro in faccia a
chiunque lo trovate in libreria perché è
uscito spero che qua dentro ci sia
scritto un po come funziona sta faccenda
del vicino visto che io 26 episodio
fatto e ancora non l'ho capito niente
direi che per l'occasione possiamo
ritirare fuori il nostro e lo nei bar
buona visione ma perché ogni vostra che
parte sto gioco c'è una cinematica
diversa una volta c'era la macchina anno
quello mi sa
sì sono io sono io ok ma come perché
giocano una intro diverso ogni volta
cosa aperte che giocare a palla in mezzo
alla strada non mi sembra l'idea più
brillante che tu abbia mai avuto una tua
vita è però piega il monache urla eccolo
c'è il vicino che sta facendo delle cose
cosa c'è di strano capi madonna vanta
grosso sta casa ma scusami enorme va
bene atto uno qual è la casa del mio
vicino esattamente credo che i miei
primi tentativi debbano essere cercare
di entrare in casa mi sa che mi ha visto
porca vacca cosa ci fai qui via cosa ci
fai fuori mi servirebbe ai delle pietre
equa
ce l'ho fatta sono entrato porco demonio
mi sono cagato addosso signor vicino mi
scusi è cambiato tutto hanno aggiornato
tutte bellissimo cavolo non lo sapevo
avesse ragionato così tanto vediamo se
riesco a entrare in casa in modo un po
più sneaky che in italiano dire in ninja
cosa fare scemo ma è roba tua quella
cosa fai lo stretching ragazzo tipo cioè
malato il problema qui vorrei andare da
qualche parte vorrei riuscire a entrare
qui sono troppo grosso per entrare va
dentro sono state sarebbe stato molto
figo c'è diventato mille volte più
difficile rispetto a prima
una torcia qui li prendo gli oggetti
regalo eccolo ho sbagliato ho sbagliato
scherzavo brake magari semi accorcia non
mi vede posso nascondervi sotto il letto
mai ci fu soluzione migliore eccolo lì
sono sotto mai visto che ciapet che ho
avuto aveva chiudi e vuoi andare
maledizione non ci sono più perfetto
fatto un pò un casino prova spento le
luci ai nomi prendere non mi prende sul
letto non ci arrivi proprio la scarsa o
ci arriva ho sperato per un attimo ott
ok ci sono dei problemi che non capisco
ok a quanto pare il gioco è molto
diverso da prima va beh ho capito come
si lasciano gli oggetti alla prima cosa
vediamo se riesco a entrare in casa mia
cavalca schifosa difficilissimo già solo
entrare in casa mia p2 per fermare che
ci aveva porta c'era la porta pazienza
ho fatto tanto pulisco dopo riesca a
trovare robe che possono essermi utile
contro il vicino ma questa è casa mia o
e casa di un altro in realtà non
dovrebbe stare casa mia visto che
correvo col pallone in mezzo alla strada
ma dai ragazzi in casa mia non c'è
niente di strano normale
non intendo mi ha però trovato una
banana che mi tornerà utile sicuramente
per entrare in casa senza che se ne
accorga al tipo la posso lanciare
addosso a ti ho fatto un torto
incredibile per orca vacca possano mi
vedete faccio il giro riguarda opere in
teoria dovrei averlo attirato
lontanissimo quindi posso entrare qua
dentro speriamo dai quanta ci vuole la
scatola o il cestino per fare il salto
in altro che piace stino piazza cestino
molto bene perfetto non far casino o le
leon iniziare a cercare un pò giù di chi
dentro lì dietro perfetto stava per
entrare non sapevo stava per entrare
fidatevi
qui non c'è niente qua dentro dobbiamo
entrare altre stanze abbiamo sei
arrivato no
e arrivato però non mi ha visto la mia
visto molto bene molto bene ragazzi
molto bene devo trovare altre corsivo
chiavi cose del genere
vediamo non c'è niente non c'è niente
che non c'è niente non c'è niente
le chiavi 2000 seconde sto maledetto
barca vacca a me sa che fuori seles
corrompere di la finestra da qua ma
rientra in casa dalla finestra a chi ha
problemi a non mi ha visto molto bene la
vediamo se riesco a trovare le chiavi
maledette proprie quel lucchetto libro
porca vacca introvabili giuro ma c'è
anche il mezzo corridoio che non ho
controllato cavalca mi ha visto e si è
chiusa la finestra aveva beh va beh è un
parco demonio edifici così è successo ma
ogni volta che mi prende succede ma cosa
può ogni volta che mi prende succeda
qualcosa di diverso ma come lei che è
successo come cos'è sta roba qua signor
vicino si calmi subito che qua mi cassia
a pettinar le bambole si è messo a
piangere secondo me ha fatto un
incidente ha nascosto il corpo
ma sta cosa spiegano nel libro va beh
niente ragazzi alla fine si sono
rigenerate tutte e io ancora non ho
capito come dovrei prendere la chiave ma
scusa un attimo ma se provassi a cosa
fai scemo con la secondo me ce li
propone comunque va bè diciamo sio ecco
tipo le scatole qua prova a prendere le
scatole no e se magari adesso se si leva
prova a fare quello che volevo fare
prima parte che è veramente qua vicino
lo zio a nomi prendi tanto sono in alto
non ci prima mitiche 6 lebron james ma
scusami vabbè mi ami ha preso facciamo
finta di niente
l'effetto c arrivato però non so se
serve di la tassa rosa però ho fatti non
c'è niente che mai alla morte
forse dovrei prendere le scapole può
essere ci arrivi a prendere l'altro dai
qua non ci può arrivare
c'è qua veramente ne deve essere
spiderman per arrivare fin qua ce l'ho
fatta non ci credo ce l'ho fatta cioè di
sopra sto male
lo spagnolo molto bene spaccato tutto ma
chi se ne frega vai tira la leva non so
cosa serve la leva tanto c'è il muro
chiuso non può arrivare impossibile che
è molto ma qui c'è una roba da fare
perfetto l'hanno trovato piano superiore
la chiave sarà qua per forza perché
sotto non c'è niente dai c'è una mira
pessima dai mannaia
no dai eppure mi sa che quella la porta
a meno che non ci possa professare
quadri a ma sono scemo sono scemo potevo
passarci tranquillamente vabbè le chiavi
la chiave o una chiave sola che mi
sembra buona chiave della chicco ma sono
sicuro che con la giusta questa per
aprire la porta di sotto c'è un'altra
codice a quanti chiavi ci sono il suo
posto prendi prendi apri apri oche e non
so come ho fatto cosa ho cliccato ma la
loro aperta ed è la prima porta poi
cessare la tirano su un ventilatore non
ho capito bene questo serve ma
accendiamo lo
v chissenefrega vabbè c'è l'ultimo
l'ultima leva qualche da tirare sicuro
che apre la porta di mezzo perfetto se
posso entrare da qualche altra parte
l'acqua che non si sa mai
da qui sa che questo è tutto però va beh
sono stato bravissimo forza roba che non
debba tirare vedi vedi che ho tirato sul
collo come ho fatto
se vedremo attivato una roba però non so
come ho fatto a dirlo vabbè ho tirato
sull'affare lì come ci arrivo di su vi
faccio giro parecchia vacca non è preso
non mi ha preso per un niente non mi ha
preso mai ha lanciato un pomodoro sto
schifo come fa a essere qua com'è
possibile come spider man ma scemo
sì va beh cosa fa mai dovrebbe va beh va
beh impossibile o ce l'ho fatta sfondati
maledetta gesù
togli la sedia aprì la porta o gesù
sto male allora chiave tutti io l'ho
trovata dai a pretty he
non si apre neanche la porta c'è
difficilissimo farlo aprire
eccolo eccolo signori proprio lui
proprio lui riesce ad aprire la porta
almeno familiare che c'è dopo curiosità
mia la vedo molto difficile però va bene
ok c'è una porta dietro una lavatrice
questa nuova la carino ma cos'è lo
vedrai continuiamo nei prossimi giorni
però è stato molto figo
spero che inizia per cento ragazzi come
al solito si è visto è piaciuto fare un
momento è un mi piace anche perché come
dice la descrizione siena seta prestiti
scheletri e non ci rivediamo a un
prossimo video beh ragazzi
[Musica]